- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
Today we're learning more
about Baker versus Carr.
A landmark supreme court
case decided in 1962.
Baker versus Carr grappled with
an incredibly important issue.
Whether one person's vote is
equal to another person's vote.
That seems pretty straight
forward to us now,
but as we'll learn in this video,
before Baker versus Carr,
it wasn't always the case.
To learn more, I talked with two experts.
Theodore Olson is a partner at
the law firm of Gibson Dunn,
and served as solicitor
general of the United States
from 2001 to 2004.
Charles is the Edward Ellen
Schwarzman professor of law
and the founding director
of the Duke Law Center
on law, race, and politics.
Mr. Olson, could you kind
of set the stage for us.
What was the overall historical
and political context
that led up to the issues
of Baker versus Carr.
- [Olson] Well, it is a very,
very important decision.
Earl Warrent who was
chief justice at the time
the case was decided later said
that it was one of the most
important decisions of his
tenure as chief justice.
Prior to the decision
in Baker versus Carr,
and a couple of subsequent decisions,
legislatures throughout
the country were organized
in a way based upon geography
and other considerations
rather than population.
We take the phrase one person,
one vote for granted now.
But prior to that time,
rural counties particularly,
all over the United States,
dominated state legislators
and individuals in cities, particularly,
might be electing one
representative when a rural county
or a rural geographical area, much smaller
in terms of population, would also have
the same amount of votes.
So there was a disproportionate weight
to smaller communities
based upon population,
which had very significant
political consequences with
respect to allocation of money
and resources and the like.
- [Charles] So in the US
we draw lines as a way of
aggregating voters
together so that way we can
elect people to various
representative bodies.
So the process of doing
so, drawing the lines,
is called, depending on when
it's done, reapportionment
or redistricting or districting.
So we draw lines through districts
for the purposes of representation.
And that has been the practice
in the US for basically
time immemorial, but the way
of districting for the
purpose of representation.
Well, many states, especially
in the late 19th century
to early 20th century, refused.
They drew the lines, in
the case of Tennessee,
they drew the line in 1901.
That was the last time they reapportioned
where they counted the number of voters
in the state and then they
decided how many voters
were going to be in each
particular district.
So a lot of time has passed
from 1901 to when the case
was decided in 1961, and many people moved
from the rural areas to the urban areas,
or from the rural areas to the suburbs,
and the districts were just not equal.
There weren't the same number of voters
in each particular district.
- [Kim] So this case took
place originally in Tennessee
and was brought by a
man named Charles Baker.
So who was Charles Baker
and why did he object
to how districting was done in Tennessee?
- [Olson] Well he was among
a group of citizens in a way,
like many other supreme court cases,
it's an accident that his name is the one
by which we remember the case.
So he came together,
along with some lawyers
and other citizens in this Tennessee area,
and brought the case because
of they listed the participants
as plaintiffs alphabetically,
Mr. Baker was the first one
on the list and he became the plaintiff.
There were a group of
citizens in Tennessee,
he was on the board of
judicial body in Tennessee,
but he was among several
citizens who objected
to the way the state
legislature was apportioned.
- [Instructor] Suppose
that we have a class term.
I'd say we have an AP history
class and we're deciding
I want to take the class out to dinner
and we're making two decisions,
a seafood place or a steak place.
Let's suppose that we have
10 people in the class
and we have three districts, all right.
So we're gonna make it when
the basis of the decision
of those three districts.
Okay, so we've got one
district of two people
who like seafood, another
district of two others
who like seafood, and a district
of six people who like steak, all right.
But we're gonna decide
on the basis of the votes
of each of the districts and
the outcome, the majority
of the votes in the district
will decide the outcome.
So remember the first
district had two people
and both of those people like seafood.
Our second district also had two people,
and both of those like seafood.
And our third district had six people,
and those six like steak.
Now, on the basis of the
decision of the district, right,
so each district counts for one vote,
seafood wins two to one, all right.
But, if you look at the
total number of people
and the total preferences,
there are actually six people
who like steak and four
people who like seafood.
So really, the decision
should be in favor of steak
as the majority of the
people or the voters
in that classroom preferred
steak over seafood.
But we can rejigger that
outcome by just dividing
the people into districts
and dividing them
into unequal districts, and then saying
each district gets one vote.
Well, for all intents and purposes,
this is exactly what Tennessee had done.
They basically divided
the state into districts
so that way, and elect
representatives from that district.
But some districts only
had let's say 100 people,
and others had 1,000
people, and some had 400,
some had 10,000, I'm
making up the numbers here,
but just to give you an example
of what the disparities were like.
But each counted essentially as one.
Each district had one vote,
even though they weren't
equal in the number of people
that were in the district.
When a student comes to me
and says, well, wait a minute,
there are many more
people who prefer steak,
it's a majority.
I'm not going to change the
system because the system
reflects my preferences and it was
the same thing in Tennessee.
The state legislature did
not have the incentive
to change the system because if they did
they would lose their seats.
- [Kim] So it's pretty quirky.
This is of course, the
supreme court is turning to
the Constitution for its interpretation.
So what does the Constitution say
about apportioning representatives?
Does it make any mention of how
districts are supposed the be drawn?
- [Olson] It does not.
It's very interesting
that our Constitution,
as everyone knows, gives
two senators for each state
and then apportions the
house of representatives
by district, which is
required to be redetermined
every 10 years after the census.
But, prior to Baker versus Carr,
there was very little
regard to the fact that
some districts were more
populous than other districts,
which meant that an individual
voter in a populous district,
who had the same amount,
had a vote, that was diluted
in a sense that he shared that vote,
or that weight of his vote
with many more persons.
And this was rampant all
over the United States.
In California, Los Angeles County had,
which was 40 percent of the population
of the state of California,
had one representative
because it was a county and
it had lots of people in it.
And then there were three smaller counties
who had very, very few
people, maybe had 10 or 15,000
people in the county, and they
each had one vote as well.
- [Kim] So Charles Baker
takes this case to the courts,
and then what happens?
How does this case make
its way through the courts?
- [Charles] Well, the
one thing to think about,
the reason why Baker versus
Carr is such an important case,
we have to remember
that the federal courts
and particulars through the
United States Supreme Court
had said in a case called
Colegrove versus Green,
look, we, the federal courts,
are not going to involve
ourselves in any of these
redistricting type cases.
We don't wanna have
anything to do with them.
We don't believe we have
the power to hear them,
so in '46, the court said
we don't have the power
to hear these cases and
no matter what happens,
those are cases that belong
to the political process.
Those are not cases that
belong in the federal courts.
And large part, an important
part because we don't think
the constitution has anything
to say about those cases.
- [Olson] So when it got
to the supreme court again
in Baker versus Carr, the question was
whether the court would
reverse that earlier decision
and decide this is something
that we, as a court,
can deal with as opposed to something
that must remain in the political realm.
And the case was argued twice,
in April of 1961 and
again in October of 1961.
The court set it for rearguement
because the first time
it was argued, one of the
justices was undecided
and they were divided four to four
and they decided to set
it for reargument again.
And when the case was then decided after
the second argument, the
court ruled six to two.
One of the justices
became disabled at the end
of the deliberation, so it was
only eight rather than nine.
But they decided six to two
the narrow, relatively narrow
question, not one person one
vote, but the narrow question
is this something that the Constitution
gives us permission to decide.
And reciting the 14th
amendment to the Constitution
which contains the well known due process
and equal protection clause,
the court and Baker versus Carr
decided we can look at the
Constitution to discern from
the equal protection clause that there is,
and due process clause, but mostly
the equal protection clause,
there is a basis for us
to decide that it might
violate an individuals
constitutional right to
equal protection of the laws.
If they're placed in a political
situation where their vote
counts less than someone else's vote.
- [Charles] And so that's
the way that the court
got around that question.
And the technical legal
term is to say that
these cases are justiciable,
which means that the courts
can hear them, that the
federal courts have the power
to decide these types of cases.
Now, the court did not
decide the second question in
Baker versus Carr, which is okay.
Suppose that it's true, right,
which if the court says
it's so, it is now true,
that federal courts do
have the power to make
those decisions, how do we
determine what is the standard
that we're going to use
to determine whether
the constitution is violated?
And that question the
court put off to the side.
The court said something
to the effect that look,
we know that there are
standards, they are available.
What we're deciding now
is that we have the power
because the equal
protection clause, in fact,
means that the state
can't draw lines that are
so malapportioned that they undermine
the equality of voters.
- [Kim] Baker versus
Carr says that the courts
then can rule on redistricting.
Did this bring in a flood of
cases about redistricting?
- [Olson] It did.
Once the court decided
that this was fair game,
that this was appropriate
for courts to consider
whether or not disparities
in voting power as a result
of packing people into different districts
in different ways constituted a violation
of the Constitution, then
in a relatively short term
by supreme court standards
in 1963 and 1964 and other
decisions that all came about
before the end of the '60's.
The court pronounced in case
after case that one person,
one vote did indeed have to,
was required by the Constitution.
So, Baker versus Carr
opened the door for a stream
of decisions from the
supreme court that put
into our constitutional fabric the concept
of one person one vote.
Which changed probably more than anything,
the structure of our political government
in the United States.
- [Kim] Do you think that
our election system today
conforms to this standard
of one person one vote?
- [Olson] Well, we probably haven't solved
all of the problems, but
compared to where we were
in 1961 before Baker versus Carr,
we've really crossed that rubicon.
Most districts are relatively equal.
There is a census every 10
years so that we can count
the number of persons in districts.
There's still cases that come along,
there are cases involving
the allocation of persons
by race and whether there
are systems in place
that discriminate on the basis of race.
- [Charles] Some states
have passed laws requiring
voters to present photo
identification when the voter goes
to vote at the polling place.
And one objection to the photo
ID is that it's a violation
of the equal protection clause.
It's a violation of the idea
of of equality that voters
are not being treated
equally via 71 and other
because some voters have
voter ID's and others
have a hard time getting
them for whatever reason.
And there are some, there might be
racial disproportionate
effects, might be class effects,
there might be gender effects.
So this raises a violation of
the equal protection clause
and these are the types of
arguments that are now available
to someone challenging the
problem of inequality in voting
pose after Baker v. Carr
that were not available
before that Baker versus Carr.
And to fully answer your
question, some people might be say
look, we don't fully
have one person one vote
because we have a lot of laws
that treat voters unequally.
- [Olson] If the political
party A, controls both houses
of a legislature in a
particular state and the person
who's in the governors
mansion, then those lines can
be drawn to favor that political party.
So that you might have situations
where a political party
maybe only has 40 percent
of the registered voters
in a particular state, but
maybe 55 percent of the
elected representatives.
That's called political gerrymandering.
And those issues have
come before the court.
- [Charles] We still haven't
achieved the type of equality
that was promised by
the Baker line of cases.
- [Kim] So we've learned
that in Baker versus Carr
the supreme court ruled that redistricting
was a justiciable issue, or something
that the federal courts could decide
because ensuring that
votes have equal weight
is important to ensuring equal
protection under the law.
The standard of one person,
one vote opened the flood gate
for cases about equality of
representation in districting
which are still being litigated
at the supreme court today.
To learn more about Baker versus Carr,
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's resources
on US government and politics.